rien de tel que notre beau pays pour
apprécier la douceur de vivre
il s'en passe tolère de bouge je revis
n'est quand même très manga this debré
corps qui ne seraient pas d'accord pour
apprécier le charme de la ville de
chinon certainement pas les acteurs lors
du tournage
ça c'est la chambre qui a occupé ary
abittan donc incarne le personnage de
david dans le film était dans une junior
catégorie
ça c'est la venue de sa chambre ary
abittan christian clavier ou encore
chantal lauby ont donc pu apprécier
notamment la douceur de vivre de la
petite place de l'hôtel de ville
ils avaient chacun leur personnalité
avec un rôle différent avec tous très
avenant les cameramans était super les
maquilleuses été super ce vraiment une
très belle équipe
il avait été déçu par le premier opus la
ville de rabelais n'était que trop
rarement filmé à la municipalité
on a contacté quand même le producteur
pour lui dire le deuxième on aimerait
bien que ça se passe sur chine dont le
seul cinéma de la ville un cinéma encore
indépendant cette comédie française
c'est une aubaine pour redynamiser
l'activité ya beaucoup d'empressement à
voir le film l'exploit de cette semaine
pour la seconde fois et je pense que
c'est loin d'être la dernière seconde
une fois que le film est sorti ici à
deux semaines d'ici on a été bloqué
parce que tout était complet j'ai hâte
de voir surtout nos quartiers les images
de nos quartiers dans le film justement
avec des supers acteurs français donc
vraiment très hâte d'être à ce soir pour
voir le film
un succès donc populaire et locales et
pour surfer sur cette notoriété
grandissante
la mairie envisage de lancer d'ici l'été
prochain
un parcours sur les traces de la famille
verneuil tout un programme en cartes
postales